what's a a boltzmann brain
a boltzmann brain is kind of a weird
fluctuation of a particle configuration
going back
actually to the very first question that
you asked me when we started this
conversation
so in the far future there will just be
these particles wafting
through the void governed by quantum
mechanics and and
every so often and route to eternity
those particles can
kind of bang into each other in an
interesting way
it won't happen often these particles
are mostly isolated
but again if you're waiting infinitely
long times or
arbitrarily long finite times weird
things can happen and one of the weird
things is particles can bang into each
other
and create or recreate a human brain out
there in the void
and that brain floating in the void can
have a thought
or two and these are called boltzmann
brains ludwig boltzmann
he didn't actually describe these things
but using his ideas
physicists of more recent vintage
have developed this idea and the weird
thing is
imagine that that brain floating in the
void just happens to have
exactly the same particle configuration
as my brain does
right now right you might say well
that's rare and i said yeah it's rare
but and route to eternity it's going to
happen rare things will happen with
essentially probability one so that
brain floating in the void
is going to think it's me it's going to
have my memories because my memories are
just
configurations of particles inside my
head right it's going to have my
personality my personality
is just the configuration of particles
inside of my head
so that brain out there in the void it's
literally gonna be
me saying oh my god how did i get here
what am i doing you know floating out
here in the void
um and that's kind of a weird a weird
idea
and and the reason we come to this it's
not like for you know some kind of
comedic
turn or something the reason we we think
about this idea is because
you have to ask yourself what is the
most likely way
that a thinking system such as ourselves
comes to be
and you come to a weird conclusion when
you invoke boltzmann brains because
there's only one biological brain that
we know of that's going to say be
me right because there isn't enough time
for multiple
me's to form in the natural biological
way
but because eternity is so far along
boltzmann brains and my brain forming
via this boltzmann random
manner that can happen arbitrarily many
times and route to eternity and so will
happen arbitrarily many times so they're
going to be like a gazillion brian
greens floating in the void if you can
think about
all of time and only one of me that
forms in the biological manner so if you
ask me
like who am i and where am i how do i
get to be
a dispassionate look at the numbers
would lead me to say
i'm a boltzmann brand that i just formed
in the void and the conversation that i
thought that we'd been having for
whatever the last half hour or so
it didn't really happen it's just a
configuration of particles inside my
head making me think that i've been
having a conversation with chris
williamson
but in reality i just formed right now
with those memories of fake things that
never actually occurred
it's kind of a weird place to get to wow
that's almost
weird but even further the even
weirdness is
it winds up being a self-defeating
conclusion because
the only reason we even anticipate the
possibility of boltzmann brains is
because
of our understanding of the laws of
physics quantum mechanics and cosmology
and we extrapolate
but if boltzmann brains are real then
my recollection of having learned
quantum mechanics
and having learned general relativity
that's also false
and the data that i thought supported
quantum mechanics and
general relativity and because that's
also just a fiction of the particle
configuration of my brain right now
so so so so it winds up being a
self-defeating
conclusion where you kind of come to a
skeptical nightmare where you can't
trust anything at all so most
physicists who take these ideas
seriously are not
really envisioning that we're boltzmann
brains rather we use it as a kind of
diagnostic tool
to interrogate our theories and
hopefully
we believe we'll come to a point which
we've not reached yet
where we'll be able to suppress this
possibility of boltzmann brains
getting our confidence back in the laws
of physics as usually configured
but as yet i would say we're not we're
not quite there so this is really
a a moment of physics in progress as we
try to eliminate this
this possibility of boltzmann brains but
we have not fully done so as yet
boltzmann brain is still on the menu
yeah it reminds me a little bit of the
simulation hypothesis
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy peace